hello guys I'm real-life sensation Ryan
Wright and I'm the fictional sensation
Jerry Jerry and I today are gonna talk
about the sequel or spin-off or
something that is somehow connected to
Cloverfield 10 Cloverfield Lane
where to begin with this movie cherry
wine you take the lead oh man uh well I
gave this this movie takes place I guess
after the events of clover feeling it
must or kind of simultaneously but uh
you know I I don't know what did you
wait to take the lead by ask you be
there good alright cuz what did you
tease I'm so used to not having to do it
this movie was really cool to me cuz you
know they brought back the whole mystery
element with the trailer and everything
so we're all wondering like what kind of
movie is this gonna be and I was really
surprised I was like it's it's kind of a
slow burn sort of paranoid tension movie
for the first two nerds you know and I
thought that was a really cool different
direction to take this cuz the first one
is so manic and this one is still
intense but because you're trapped in
this really tiny space I mean it all
takes place in in a doomsday bunker for
most of it you know as I'm looking at
the camera thing go not very well you
only get one you you either get a lead
or looking at the end to get there
Cloverfield comparisons out of the way
this is it's just not there to when I
it's isn't one of those situations where
you're like through like two totally
different films these are two totally
different movies you know they are not
the same in genre or style whatsoever
this is like a domestic thriller I
really enjoy it a lot I think it's a
fantastic film and John Goodman doe man
holy [ __ ] John Kim is [ __ ] great he's
incredible in this movie [ __ ]
terrified yeah one he plays a guy who
like who almost seems like he's
borderline autistic or something like
that he's got this very strange
personality and John Goodman brings so
many little tics and nuances to that at
first I was like been doing and then
after a couple minutes I caught on and I
was like this is a great character yeah
it's a great character because you know
you can't tell for a long time whether
he's evil or not I'm not going to tell
you if in the end you find out if he is
evil or not it's usually under yeah cuz
there are times where you're like this
is a scary [ __ ] you guys should
bail and then there are other times
where the characters are trying to like
him and you're like that makes sense
where they start to like him at this
particular moment do it based off of
work
seems the psychology of what they do
with John
means character is one of the best parts
of this movie I think this I called you
the whole the carrot yeah is it is a
definite strength and it's cool because
there are things I can point to in the
acting and the writing that make these
works so well yeah you know cuz it's the
scenes they choose to give you because
this isn't like a frantic it's almost
kind of not like a big Hollywood movie
yeah it's not even like crazy Lee
stylistic shot in this one location you
know there are some stylistic shots but
for the most part it's captured like a
rather normal film you know well yeah
and it's almost captured sort of it in a
more indie way cuz it's like exact they
start with this with this whole thing
about like Oh something is wrong with
her relationship with her boyfriend
she's you know cutting and running and
stuff like that and then you know is a
place we often start for these movies
and they found a way to like the list
yeah a little bit yeah I mean kinda and
then and you know just like we love
domestic hardship as the stock like
character development tool but this felt
actually natural and actually like it
was a real situation she was going
through it even though like the trailers
don't tell you much I still thought like
well the I've seen the trailer multiple
times and I have a feeling I know how
this will play out
yeah it doesn't play out the way you
make might allude you to believe it will
play out this way yeah I wasn't quite
sure what to expect yeah it's like
things there's a lot of time where I'm
like what direction is just gonna go
down in it like well with that you know
plot turn how's this gonna unfold the
other thing too is is I think they
really got smart about writing this
movie because they give you a whole
other creepy subplot to focus on yeah so
partway through you're like this is
[ __ ] up and I'm not even we haven't
even seen a creature yet so they took
the time to really pack their characters
with stuff going Alan just in this tiny
world so that the tiny world is just as
scary as the big world for completely
different reasons I think it's like more
engaging than the first Cloverfield
totally because you just we just
rewatched Cloverfield and mega move to
get together movie doesn't have a lot in
terms of characters that movie is all
about the immediacy and the thrill and
this sort of creature yeah putting you
right in a city being destroyed and this
takes the complete opposite this is
almost like alien and aliens but in
Reverse yeah because it's like this one
takes this sort of we're gonna
really confine this and we're gonna
really take our time and tightly unweave
a mystery I wouldn't say it's slow burn
thriller though it's this time it takes
its time but I wouldn't call it slow
slow burn it doesn't mean slow the slope
it means I know but you and it well I
say it's like so yeah it's not how
sometimes you watch a slow burn thriller
you're like this is a slow move it moves
movies only like an hour and a half hour
and 45 minutes yeah it moves along but
it's not you know particularly fast and
it's never boring cuz it's tense and
uncomfortable and then you kind of start
to like people and then other things
come into play and so like there's a
whole lot going on mary elizabeth
winstead whoa no flowers yeah dude she
is so [ __ ] good in this movie yeah
she's she's incredibly natural and again
like you know you could say like oh this
is silly alien movie and stuff like that
she is us like she's her story we're
along the ride with her specifically and
you know we know her sympathetically
yeah the other two guys we don't know
and she does a really good job of
playing those moments naturally and
rarely in a film like this do you get a
good character arc when this movie was
over I was like I didn't expect the
character argue does it work well here
everybody brought their a-game to this
movie like all the actors and I think in
the writing too and and I noticed one of
the writers was the guy wrote whiplash
yeah like so they've doubled down on
their on their script the movies
unpredictable and it keeps you on your
toes and it keeps you engaged because
the interaction with the characters is
fantastic and John Gallagher jr. as
Emmett when I saw the trailer I was I
had an idea of what the character might
be like yeah I wasn't expecting him to
be so likable and in a non cliche way
they seem like a real dude like a
genuine real this it felt like this
seems like this could be a real guy you
know they took that approach to the
character development of like what would
these people talk about if they were in
a room together ya know it's not like
two hours we have to get out of here
yeah how you know they're [ __ ] bored
in a bunker like this sometimes it's
just the lifestyle living in that bunker
yeah and it becomes so engrossing part
because you know they bothered to write
these characters and partly because each
of them the three of them are really
good and every nuance and every
character of the main three I was like
these are characters that are easy to do
fine like after a couple minutes of
watching everyone I was like man like
Mary Lou who's Winstead is doing a great
job
that John Goodman comes on screen and
then he started like really impressing
me and then John Gallagher jr. I was
yeah this guy could be the weak link but
no even he brought the a game I like
critics I've already revealed that yes
there is some creature stuff in here
what I think there wasn't gonna be yeah
no okay first off it would suck if there
was yeah I was like this might help this
movie is I'm like if there's not a
single gonna be upset no that would be
kind of a bummer not saying anything but
they don't forget about you yeah what
it's what's cool is it's rather brief in
a sense however it gets you thinking
about how the Cloverfield world has
expanded yeah I don't like it makes you
weird yeah it makes you think of it as a
world yeah yes I think the greatest
improvement this movie makes over the
first one is that this one feels like a
real world and a real story where it's
like if Yuri watch Cloverfield it's fun
and there's some things they do really
well but you're still like it's a fun
entertaining monster flick but you can
kind of see the funhouse wall yeah
exactly this is this is not that yeah
you know this is like wow this is a
whole situation I would love to explore
and see more of you know it's weird is
like it's a psychological drama for the
most part but we saw this on IMAX and I
think it was totally worth it you watch
it on IMAX I thought it was like totally
worth it well this is kind of nother
they're similar but this is kinda like
ex machina is like it's so tense even
though it's just people talking in a
small space and like they did that same
thing they really built the dread up
yeah used how small everything is to
really never let you be entirely
comfortable yeah yeah and it's a
disorienting location too cuz it's like
it's not most people haven't seen the
inside of a doomsday bunker yeah how
kind of strange that must be cuz part of
it almost looks like a living room and
then part of it was just like an awful
storage shed
dude that's a movie I [ __ ] sticks
with you man like the more I think about
it the more I'm like that was an intense
[ __ ] thriller I was impressed by this
and that was the last thing I was
expecting not that I wasn't expecting to
be impressed
impressed for different reasons I was
like man you really made a good film I
think with ya not just a fun monster
flick this is one of those films that
work that's like it got released early
in the year because of the genre from
the marketing it's probably not gonna
get the recognition it deserves
come award season when the script in
here is [ __ ] amazing
yes solid [ __ ] screenplay John
Goodman deserves a combination really
good that's the thing is like we have
all these young adult stories that are
like about alien invasion yeah things
like that this felt like even though
there's no book to go with it I was like
this seems like like the literature
version of that I was like it appeals to
the popcorn crowd but this is a really
interesting little sci-fi story and this
must be the first time where it's been
successfully done where they continued a
world that started off from
found-footage and then just put it in
film's format I think it's the first
time flash sideways war really yeah it's
like yeah you know like beyond that like
I know like rectum legs wreck almost God
that is split this one people are pretty
unanimous and this is a very good movie
well I think they took the right
approach and I've noticed this across a
lot of different artistic platforms like
if you just take your time before coming
back and especially with the Cloverfield
cuz the whole element of surprise was
such a big thing they took their time
and found a way to recreate that yeah
and that makes it all the more special
when they get it right I really hope
they don't just start dishing out
Cloverfield movies that's my hope too
and I hope the next one it's like I
would like if they do another one change
the type of movie a little bit again and
and let's have some new characters just
keep that going yeah I mean it's really
well shot as well edited for the most
part I mean there may be a couple of
scenes where like you know the actions a
little garbled I guess if needed nitpick
I guess the one thing is because
Cloverfield exists the movie in some
ways cuz you really don't need to see
the first Cloverfield at all like
there's not a single reason you don't
watch it to get this movie it'll affect
your experience exactly because of the
fact that when you're watching this film
if you've seen Cloverfield you want to
see a creature at least at one point and
haven't seen Cloverfield this is your
first time watching it you won't care
for that
if a creature does appear it'll be more
of a surprise yeah unfortunately most
people have seen Cobra filled and the
people are interested have seen
Cloverfield already yeah knowing
Cloverfield it does at least come into
your mind sometimes where you're like oh
they got those little spider alien
things like what if one of those like
breaks it or something yeah you know you
have an idea of other creatures we
haven't you started to forget about it
you do you do it I think it's like you
may be sitting there for the first half
hour not like obsessing over it but it
may cross your mind and then at a
certain point you realize oh [ __ ] I'm
just I'm just locked in this yeah this
little tiny space is just as compelling
as anything else outside that's what's
cool is like the mystery of what's going
on outside is it's not Cloverfield and
that's it you know it's not the first
movies going on outside you like you're
hearing like stuff that's I don't wanna
give anything away but you're like that
wasn't in the first movie yeah it makes
you go what is it is the fans is a
really subtle way I just think for the
third Cloverfield they should bring back
TJ Miller
we found except they like he said he's
like a half robot now he's a Grove Oh
copy wood Oh Bear McCreary from The
Walking Dead did the music - the music's
pretty cool music is pretty damn good
well guys um my rating would have to be
I give it a hundred Greg's puts a Greg I
mean after a guy Greg Alba like I
wouldn't be here if it wasn't for him
he's a good guy he's much more sincere
much kinder than myself
yeah same size penis we actually look
doing okay but we're not the same God if
he commits a crime like you know how are
they gonna tell you apart I'll the
sketch what if they come so sorry okay
they'll get Greg okay yeah Ryan and
going anywhere Joe and I give it like
twenty seven hundred Jerry's good good
anyway do dads and dudes and
hermaphrodites if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to day two the
real rejects don't worry we've got
transgender people on here we got some
people she man I just don't know if that
was the term reasons to see Jerry Harry
reasons - Jerry has playlist on the real
Reid
Jaxson dank ass stubs it's like Jerry's
miniature shows inside of the real
rejects and also follow us on our social
networks like the Facebook's the
Instagram the Twitter's if anything
happens to John Goodman in a like if he
gets like molested or something oh we're
gonna find that guy kill him and serve
Him to John Goodman John Goodman will
eat the pedophile that touch time how
did you get to here